hello and welcome
my name is jennifer davis and i'm happy
to be here today to discuss with you
the detection of typical gcms pesticides
in cannabis matrix
utilizing apci lcms
hopefully by the end of this
presentation you've learned a little bit
about
something of the following what mass
spectrometry is
lcms versus gcms the general pesticide
analysis in cannabis different source
types that we
offer mrm development final method
parameters used the sample preparation
used
what matrix effects were seen and then
the resulting data that was actually
acquired in this application
first let's start with mass spectrometry
in general mass spectrometry is an
analytical technique that takes a
compound of interest and ionizes it
each ion is then separated based on its
mass to charge ratio
using some type of mass analyzer and
then detected
the final result is a mass spectrum
which plots signal intensity versus the
ion's mass to charge ratio
there are a variety of different ion
sources or mass analyzers that can be
used
throughout this discussion we will focus
on the use of tandem mass spectrometry
this type of mass spectrometry utilizes
a set of quadrupoles for the mass
separation
this will be combined with the use of
esi or apci for the ionization
techniques
i will go into further detail in a
little bit about what exactly a
quadrupole is and how it works as well
as the different ionization techniques
we offer
the first example of tandem mass
spectrometry i will discuss
is liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry or also known as
lcms this type of analysis uses ultra
high performance liquid chromatography
or uhplc for the separation of the
analytes prior to their detection
generally speaking the combination of
lcms allows for a highly selective and
sensitive detection method
for analyzing complex samples lcms
offers the benefit of not needing to
achieve baseline resolution for all of
the analytes
unlike when you're using just uh plc
this can help increase sample throughput
and shorten the overall run time needed
in a laboratory
a second example of tandem mass
spectrometry is gas chromatography mass
spectrometry
also known as gcms while both gc and lc
are an analytical technique used for
separation
and both are coupled to a tandem mass
spectrometer they have one major
difference
gas chromatography requires analytes to
be separated based on their volatility
or boiling point
and uses an inert gas during separation
this requires the analyte of interest to
be thermally stable
the downside with this is a huge number
of analytes decompose at a high
temperature
and therefore cannot be analyzed using
gcms
with the increase in medicinal and
recreational cannabis legislation
throughout the united states
there is an increasing demand for
pesticide testing on cannabis products
pesticides can be insecticides
herbicides fungicides
basically any product that is used to
help protect a crop from harmful
organisms
and get it all the way to a successful
growth and harvest
the problem is pesticides are believed
to cause both short-term and long-term
health problems in humans
because of this there is an initial
regulatory guidelines that are set
within the cannabis market this
guideline is being set by each state
individually
this results in a variation between the
number of analytes tested
and the required action limits from
state to state for example california
regulates a total of 66 pesticides
and oregon regulates a total 59. due to
the volatility of some of these
pesticides
laboratories currently require the use
of both lcms and gcms to analyze the
complete list
this study evaluates using apci lcms
for the quantitation of compounds
frequently analyzed by gcms
so what is apci and why can it offer an
alternative to gcms
normally when using lcms pesticides are
analyzed with esi or electrospray
ionization
this is the process of infusing a liquid
through a capillary and then applying a
high voltage to it as it passes into the
mass spec source
this creates charged droplets that are
continuously evaporated until the sample
ions are released into the gaseous state
once in this gaseous state the ions can
travel into the inlet of the mass spec
and along the ion path for detection
in apci or atmospheric pressure chemical
ionization however
the sample is vaporizing using a heater
before entering the mass spec source
because the sample is already in the
gaseous state a corona needle is used to
apply an electrical discharge that can
then ionize molecules in the gaseous
state
this allows us to analyze more volatile
compounds while still using lcms
a third ionization source was tested
during the study called dual ionization
or duos this is a compromise between esi
and apci utilizing the esi probe
in combination with the corona needle
discharge
i am going to quickly demonstrate when
using a shimatsu lcms 8060
how to switch from the electrospray
ionization source
to the atmospheric pressure chemical
ionization source or the apci source
the total process of switching from one
source to another takes
less than 30 seconds and can be easily
done by
any user
in the beginning of this study the
initial evaluation included q1 and q3
scans
using electrospray ionization or esi
dual ionization or duos and atmospheric
pressure chemical
ionization or apci every pesticide
currently run by gcms was tested
not only were they run using all these
different ionization techniques
they were actually run using hot and
cold temperature settings
and with and without additives in the
mobile phase all of this initial scan
data was then processed to determine the
best ionization source
and conditions for each pesticide in
this particular example shown
pentachloronitrobenzene or quintazine
showed the best ionization using apci
an in-source rearrangement was seen that
was temperature dependent
under colder temperature settings the
precursor could be driven into one
particular state
or under hotter temperature settings two
viable precursors were
noted after the initial scans and source
testing was completed
any viable precursors were then selected
for msms scans
this was used to determine their
fragmentation patterns continuing the
example previously used
pcmb under hotter temperature settings
had two viable precursors
264 and 275. both of these were treated
to a number of msms scans
along a range of collision energies as
you can see in the spectrums displayed
above
they gave a similar but slightly
different fragmentation pattern
depending on the precursor selected
both precursors had one to five
transitions selected
and then was further optimized the final
transitions were tested in both cannabis
matrix and as a neat solution
so what exactly is an mrm and why are we
using it an mrm or multiple reaction
monitoring
is a very selective approach for the
identification and quantitation of a
variety of analytes
this is an example of tandem mass
spectrometry that uses two quadrupoles
for double mass filtration
it offers a great way to get good data
with a high degree of specificity and
sensitivity
during an mrm a specific precursor ion
of interest is selected and then passed
into the collision cellar q2
the precursor then undergoes
fragmentation and the product ions or
fragments are then passed into q3 where
a specific fragment can then be selected
for detection
this process of selecting a precursor
and then a fragment specific to this
precursor
is what allows us to have that high
level of specificity and sensitivity
after source testing and mrm
optimization was completed
the final method parameters were
selected to be tested in cannabis matrix
the table at the top shows the final mrm
transitions used when testing in
cannabis extract for all 10 analytes
the interface settings shown are all of
the gas or temperature settings used
as well as the lc flow rate and
injection volume
the final hplc gradient had a total run
time
of 15 minutes and used a c18 column
the sample preparation used in this
study took one gram of dried flour
and 10 mls of acetonitrile and added
them to a clean 50 ml falcon tube
three steel balls were then added to aid
in the grinding of the sample in
combination with vortexing for five
minutes
centrifugation was then performed for
five minutes at 2800 rpm
and the supernatant transferred to a
vial for injection onto the lcms
both a spiked and unspiked sample were
treated to this extraction process for
the initial method testing
the spike sample included adding 50
microliters of a 40 microgram per ml
stock solution of all 10 pesticides
the final on flour spiked concentration
was equivalent to 2 000 nanograms per
gram
the sample preparation technique just
discussed was done with a dry
flower there are a variety of different
matrices in cannabis as well
such as flowers edibles concentrates
tinctures
topicals because of all these different
matrices as well as the ever-growing
introduction of new ones it's difficult
for analytical chemists to account for
all the different matrix effects that
can occur
generally speaking matrix effect is a
result of all components other than the
target analyte
and their effect on the overall
ionization in the case of cannabis
matrix
a number of these effects can come from
cannabinoids
terpenes phospholipids or even the
ingredients used in the making of
edibles or concentrates
and sometimes even the extract process
itself
basically when matrix effect occur it
can result in poor data
it can cause inaccurate quantification
false positives or negatives or an
overall reduction in sensitivity
in the examples above i demonstrate it
one example of matrix suppression from
cannabis flower and two examples of
matrix interference
all three of the chromatograms show a
neat standard at 6.25 parts per billion
that would be the green trace and the
same transition in a cannabis
extract at 6.25 parts per billion
or nanograms per gram on flower
concentration
which is shown in the black trace
in the first example all the way on the
left hand side with chlordane
i'm demonstrating matrix suppression so
the green trace and the black trace
actually have a concentration difference
of 10 times the neat standard is 10
times lower than that of the cannabis
extract
but yet the signal intensity is still
very similar
clearly demonstrating that in the
cannabis extract itself
there is some form of suppression
occurring during the ionization process
the other two examples are of matrix
interference
in the case of mgk264 or the middle
chromatogram you can see a decrease in
the overall signal to noise
you can also see that there is quite a
bit of increase in that
baseline itself making the quantitative
quantitation a little bit more
challenging
in the last example in the chromatogram
all the way to the right
this was done with cyfluthrin and this
was a severe case of matrix interference
the actual surrounding peaks have such a
higher signal intensity than that of the
analyte peak itself
it was barely detectable because this
interference was so severe we actually
didn't even end up using this transition
for the final analysis
after all the method development was
completed which included
source testing mrm optimization
the optimization of different source
parameters
chromatographic optimization using a
variety of different gradients and
column types
and then the last step was the canvas
extract process
itself once this was all completed the
final samples were loaded into an auto
sampler
and a real time batch was begun
i have a short clip to demonstrate
what the actual real-time analysis looks
like inside the lab solutions software
after data acquisition you can open up
your data and post on analysis
for a quick check that all analytes have
been found and their rent retention
times confirmed before quantitation
here are some example chromatograms from
the final apci
lcms analysis that was completed the
bottom chromatogram clearly demonstrates
that using a shimatsu lcms 8060
with the apci lcms method
up to 10 analytes were quantitated and
accurately identified
the top four chromatograms are just
individual chromatograms
of four of these analytes that were in
the overall method
all four chromatograms clearly
demonstrate a nice peak shape
and easily detectable at their action
limits
matrix matched calibration curves were
prepared using
cereal dilution and a spiked flour
extract the calibration ranges from
2000 nanograms per gram to 7.8 nanograms
per gram on flour concentration
the final range varied for each
individual analyte and whatever their
necessary action limit was
all calibration curves were plotted
using peak area versus concentration
with a 1 over c weighting as you can see
all of the curves demonstrated linearity
with an r square of 0.992 or better
all curves were followed by a qc and a
blank to evaluate the overall system
performance
and to do a carryover assessment
the use of an apci lcms method
clearly demonstrated that all loqs
were well below the necessary action
limits set by both california or
oregon the loqs reported for each
pesticide had a signal-to-noise ratio
greater than 10
and had a percent rsd value less than 20
percent
and the table displayed you can clearly
see what the the set action limits were
for both california and oregon for all
10 of the analytes of interest
and what the actual observed loq was
seen
on the lcms 8060 using an apci
ionization technique
and with that i have come to the end of
my discussion
hopefully everyone has learned something
new i'd like to take a quick second to
say
thank you to milipor as well as shimatsu
for offering the opportunity for me to
discuss this
if you would like any additional
information about anything discussed
during this presentation please feel
free to go to www.growyourlab.com
[Music]
hello my name is shikema sharzai i work
for milliport sigma
as an application and training
specialist in this video i'll tell you a
little bit about mcmediapath
and how to do testing on the mc media
pads to start with the mc media pads we
have a variety of them we have the
rapid aerobic count we have the yeast
and mold one
and then we have the e coli and coliform
pads as well so the really interesting
features that
the mc media pads carry are that they
come color coded
so on the package and as well as the
individual
mc media pads they have their color
coded so
then you can differentiate besides the
color coding on the package each packet
comes with 25 pads in them
the storage temperature is right on the
package itself
and the package and the mc media pad
both have the lot number and the
expiration date
on them so that way you don't mix up the
lot numbers with different packages um
also the mc media pad also has the essay
that you're planning on running the
initial of it right on the pad
the really cool thing about the mc media
pad is they come with a
transparent lid which is used as a
protector
when you're incubating so no
contamination can get in your
pads um each pad is consist of the
non-woven
fabric which is engineered in such a way
that when you
inoculate with your one mil sample
it diffuses the sample evenly that
there's no leakage outside that
once you're done you close your mc media
path and you
put it in the incubator to incubate for
the appropriate temperature it needs to
be so come with me and i'll show you how
to do testing on the mc media pants
for the mc media pad testing you need
your appropriate pads
you need one mil pipetter you need one
mil pipette tips
you need your sample you need a waste
bucket
so let's start with the testing you'll
grab your one mil
pipette tips
your draw up your sample
for the mc media media pad you'll go on
the corner of the
pad lift the transparent lid
and peel it diagonally like this
you'll take your sample and you will
dispense it in the middle
without touching the pad as you can see
dispensing it evenly without requiring
additional tools now you'll close your
transparent lid slowly like this
if you notice that there may be bubbles
close to the non-volume fabric all you
need to do is take your index
finger and go around the uh
non-moving fabric without without
touching the fabric
what this will do is eliminate any
bubbles
and that gives you a better reading when
you have your samples
and then this can be stacked in the
incubator
up to 20 pad on top of each other
and incubate it for the appropriate time
and temperature per the essay required
this is two pads after incubation time
one has more colonies one has a little
bit of less colonies to do your counting
as i said before the transparent lid
provides a grid helps you for easy
counting
for for the colonies as you can see
so you can count the colonies with the
clicker
if you have one and go over each
colonies and count them
however if you want automatic system
there is an automatic system in the
market
it's called the scan 1200 it comes from
a company
named entersign it basically does the
counting for you
automatically it does read the mc media
pad
as well as petri dishes load the mc
media pad
on the skin you simply just go ahead and
put the pad on it
and as you can see on the computer it
loads up your sample
so it provides many features for you
where
you can play around and to change the
total cfus that you're looking for
the characteristics of cfus
to as well as the display type that you
may be looking for
also it provides the sample number how
many samples you have
and if you want dilution factor included
however for this for this pad we're
basically do
we're gonna do a count
and then validate
and it does account for you it
recognized 13 colonies
and the dilution factor was one so this
is the automatic version if you're
interested in
knowing how to do this automatically i
hope you enjoyed the video
feel free to reach out to any of us at
miliport
and we'll be happy to assist you thank
you for watching
hello and thank you for attending
millipour sigma's canna lab workshop
my name is kelly massey and i'm a senior
field marketing specialist for our
biomonitoring division
we specialize in microbiology solutions
for the pharmaceutical
food and beverage and cannabis
industries
today i'm going to be talking a little
bit about environmental monitoring and
sanitation verification
which are key to good production
practices and following hassep in your
growing or production environments for
cannabis products
em can provide critical information
which can determine
if your production environment is under
control
this data can be used and analyzed to
ensure that your product is high quality
and free from any harmful microbes that
may affect product safety
and then ultimately consumer safety
sanitation control is also crucial
to check that your cleaning procedures
are effective this can be done using atp
testing
today i'm going to show you some of our
viable air monitors
our rcs high flow touch and our mas vf
as well as our mvp icon which is used
for atp testing
let's get started
today i'm going to start by talking
about viable air monitoring
testing air in your greenhouse or
production environment will give a good
indication of the bioburden levels in
the air
particularly molds testing at your site
will enable you to see trends and know
if there is any concern for the quality
of your products
we have two different viable air
monitoring options our rcs high flow
touch
and our masvf both have different
benefits and features so let's get
started
here is our mas vf instrument this is a
very easy to use
instrument with sophisticated technology
inside that makes it one of the best air
monitors on the market
it uses in the anderson principle of
impaction which draws in
air through the head of the instrument
and the bugs impact onto the media being
used
this is an open system which uses
standard 90 millimeter auger pleats
the mas vf samples at 100 liters per
minute allowing you to sample a thousand
liters of air in 10 minutes
time it is made of anodized aluminum
which makes the unit robust
and very easy to clean the instrument
has a simple interface
which enables you to pick a sample
volume with just a few clicks
or you can put all of your parameters
onto the instrument using the web-based
software
and then all you have to do is just
press start
so here's how we're going to take our
sample we have our air monitor here and
our 90 millimeter auger plates
we are going to take the head of the
instrument off
we will place our 90 millimeter auger
plate onto
the plate stand within the instrument
we would put our head back on and go
through and press play
this is going to go through and sample
at a thousand liters per minute
i went on my web-based software and
programmed a delay time of five seconds
as you can see the instrument is now
running and that will indicate with the
green blinking light at the bottom
the instrument will also go through and
show you its progression
visually as the sample is being taken
these bars will load and turn dark
as you continue to complete the sample
once your sample is finished
[Music]
we would go through we would certainly
be using a septic technique
and we would take our 90 millimeter
auger plate
we can go through and we can go and
incubate this in our lab
or we would be able to send this off to
a contract testing lab for our results
and that's how simple and easy the mas
vf is to use
here are some samples that you can see
that i've taken previously
so once you go through and you incubate
you will see growth on these agar plates
and that will be a great indication
if there are any bugs or anything of
concern
within your environment that is our mas
vf system
here is our rcs high flow touch viable
air monitor
this instrument is going to use
centrifugal impaction
instead of seed impaction like the mas
line
it will draw in the air from the
environment and spin that error
around the rotor head of the instrument
this will impact any bugs onto the media
being used
the instrument is a closed system that
uses auger strips with media such as tsa
or sda the consumables are individually
packaged
which allows you to only use what you
need and not have to throw any pleats
away
this creates less waste
here is what one of the auger strips
looks like
the instrument itself has a very
user-friendly interface
and an easy-to-use touch screen that you
can also run a sample with just a few
clicks
one of the innovative features of the
rcs is its ability
to be able to tell you approximately how
many samples you can take on its current
battery life
this is shown on the interface of the
instrument right here
what you'll see is on the current
battery life of the instrument right now
at a thousand liter sample you'll have
approximately
15 samples that you'll be able to take
on this current battery life
the instrument allows you to be able to
toggle through different sample volumes
and you can go through and set those
sample volumes
using the software for the instrument
it's going to come with seven preset
volumes a thousand liters
is going to be one of those if we want
to go through and take a sample
we would remove our protection cap which
will show us where our rotor head is
we can go through and get our media
ready we would take the rotor head off
of the instrument and this is just going
to magnetize right on top so it just
kind of clicks so you know where it goes
here you can see is where you're going
to go through and insert
your auger strip so we're going to take
that
out and this is just going to go through
and slide right into the head of the
instrument
so we're going to slide that all the way
in
make sure that tab's there this is just
going to magnetize back
on to the top of the instrument and then
we are ready
to take our sample it's as easy as just
pressing play
now the air sampler will go through and
take a thousand liters per minute
you have the ability to be able to
toggle back and forth between the
amount of time that is left or you can
go back to how much volume is left
on that interface once the sample is
finished it will beep and let you know
you would go through and remove your
protection cap
obviously using aseptic technique for
all of this
we would take our rotor head off
we would remove our auger strip
and that goes right back
into our little individually packaged or
individual packaging and then that is
what gets incubated and this is what you
take your counts from
so that should show you how easy and
simple
both of our viable air monitors are the
masvf and the rcs high flow touch
the rcs high flow touch can also be used
for compressed gas testing
so these are two great environmental
monitoring
solutions for air monitoring that we
offer for millipore sigma
hygiene testing is crucial to
determining if your sanitation sops are
effective
and if they're being followed correctly
looking for atp on a surface can help
determine the cleanliness of an area and
also measure sanitate effectiveness
this could lessen the risk of
cross-contamination between lots and
manufacturing processes
let's take a look at the mvp icon the
mvp icon is a luminometer which is used
with a surface sampling device
as you can see right here to determine
the quality and hassup related
monitoring of the environment
after you clean and sanitize the
luminometer is going to detect
microbiological residues measuring atp
using luciferase bioluminescence
atp is found in all bacteria yeast and
mold cells
the mvp icon is going to measure atp in
seconds
and then those results are going to be
displayed on the instrument
in zones of cleanliness a proprietary
scale which is adapted from rlus
those results are going to fall into a
clean pass or fail area
so corrective action can easily be
determined and immediately implemented
so here is what the mvp icon instrument
looks like
it's very ergonomically designed and
lightweight
it has a full color touch screen making
it easy and efficient to use
and you can monitor and record all your
results within the instrument
so i'm going to show you a quick
demonstration of the sample process and
how easy
it is to use
to collect a sample we need to go
through and remove the sampling device
from the tube
we're going to pop that off and we're
going to go through and sample about a
10 by 10 centimeter sample area
so i always like to say it's like a
zigzag pattern that you would go through
and use
to take a sample i'm going to use my
desk for our sample
so that you can see how this works the
sampling device is stable for one
hour prior to activation then to
activate the sample device you can see
the plunger right here
we're going to use our thumb and press
down the plunger until it's fully
depressed
so what's going to happen here is the
reagents are actually going to disperse
through the swab shaft uniformly and
this is going to release the sample
off of the swab into the bottom of the
collection tube which you can kind of
see
right there this swab is then going to
be
inserted the chamber
of the mvp icon so you can see at the
top here there's a little button
and that's going to open and show us our
chamber for the instrument
we're going to go through and place our
swab into the chamber
and then we will need to select our test
point so as you can see here there's a
little
menu option for points and that's going
to show us all of the different points
that we have loaded
i'm going to select point one and once
that
is selected then we can go through and
we can run our test
so i'm going to run that test right now
as you can see there's a progress bar
right here
it typically takes about 18 seconds so
it's a very quick
time to result if the atp level will be
detected and then you will see
whether your sample passed gives you a
warning or whether the sample failed
so now it's going to beep it's going to
let us know that our sample is complete
i'm going to go through and remove our
swap
from the chamber of the instrument and
then we'll be able to see our results
when it's going to show us that that
sample failed which really isn't
surprising on my desk
because of how many demos i've done
today and that i've been touching the
desk and i have
atp on my hands so our sample
as you can see right there very easily
tells us that that sample point would
need to be retested
and also re-sanitized one of the other
things that i wanted to talk about
quickly is the actual icon dashboard
software the mvp icon
dashboard software really sets the
instrument apart and offers performance
metrics
powerful analytical tools and
presentation ready reports to meet a
range of informational needs
so here you can see some of the
dashboard widgets which are customizable
and they give you the ability to be able
to see
trends which is really essential to the
management of your asset program
you can fully customize these widgets
and that dashboard to see what is most
important to you
as you can see on this example dashboard
here we have
the percentage of swab samples to target
we have the percentage of retests
it shows us when our next calibration
date
the atp fail rate is listed here the
retest
rates are all listed and a pass worn
fail percentage by sample point
so it's very clear and easy to see what
your trends and your results are
that is just a quick demonstration of
the mvp icon and how to take a quick
sample
well it's been fun getting to show you
some of our easy to use and innovative
products for environmental monitoring
and sanitation control
please if you have any additional
questions head over to the ask the
expert lounge
where a bio monitoring specialist is
waiting to answer any questions that you
may have
milliport stigma partners with you every
step of the way making your mission of
safe products our mission
thank you so much and have a great day